mit allem was die hatten das sei damit
zum stuhl
ich habe schon mal auf ein video von
diesem youtuber reagiert danke für das
ganze positive feedback von euch das ist
auf jeden fall massig vorhanden lieber
denn das ganz kurz annäherung freuen uns
wahrscheinlich gerade das video und sehe
gerade das ich gesagt hat das ist schon
auch ein video vom mikro sieg reagiert
hat ist allerdings nicht der fall
das video was sie gesehen habt war von
supermann dennis ich werde dieser action
noch öfter sagen dass sie schauen wir
auch ein video von mir korosec reagiert
habe ich meine damit dann allerdings
kommen denn es tut mir leid ich die
irgendwie miteinander verwechselt aber
jetzt viel spaß bei der wii action
damals ging es darum dass der sendmail
gefälscht hatte und dass viele krasser
dargestellt hatte als es wirklich war er
hat sich mit photoshop irgendwelche
wunden ins gesicht gemalt und heute
beziehungsweise vor einigen tagen ist
wieder etwas vorgefallen
wir befinden uns hier nämlich auf dem
kanal von mirko rosig für deine zukunft
sehe ich nicht so rosig als sie ihn
nicht kennen sollte der gehört zu der
clique miguel pablo also damit ihr schon
mal bescheid wisst er hat 200.000
abonnenten seinen kanal banner ist in
new york ich bezweifle dass er das foto
hier selbst gemacht hat werden
einerseits blogs aus new york den ganz
normalen titel haben dann haben wir
andererseits wieder videos wie extrem
schießt challenge versus dennis renk
geht schief plus verletzung also wir
haben hier viele verschiedene arten von
videos erlebt oft mal blogs hoch oft
aber auch irgendwelche komischen
youtuber boxen
ich weiß ja bis mitbekommen habt aber in
england hat caseking bella gekämpft und
das war so ein riesiger neuer trend dass
youtuber ihren brief sage ich mal nicht
irgendwie in videos gegen dann erklären
sondern im boxring und danach hatte case
als er deshalb gewundert hat der jackpot
und herausgefordert zwar ein riesiges
ding und jetzt gibt's das ganze
anscheinend auch in deutschland haben
uns ja gleich anschauen ob das wirklich
komplett geklautes einem heute soll es
allerdings etwas anderes gehen und zwar
um das hier blaues auge was passiert das
video hat 65.000 aufrufe und 500 discs
2600 leise also es ist auf jeden fall
ein bisschen kontrovers behandelt worden
bevor wir auf das video reagierten
schauen wir uns wie immer davor einfach
mal die tags an und zwar mit korosec
mirko boxen youtuber boxen case
einloggen paul denke ich nicht dass die
in dem video drin vorkommen werden
allerdings wie bereits vorhin schon
gesagt das komplette youtuber boxen ich
weiß noch nicht ich habe mir das video
von den noch nicht angeguckt und
bekommen das es sowas jetzt auch in
deutschland gibt der mich denke das wird
komplett von k s eye geklaut worden sein
text ansonsten komplett normal kann man
nichts gegen sagen stürzen uns jetzt mal
die kommentare sehen wir direkt check
deine ins private nachrichten bitte dass
wir einen neuen termin ausmachen können
für die box vertrag der kommentar wurde
geschrieben von diesem youtuber der
macht so des tracks und keine ahnung
irgendwie was also die kämpfen
anscheinend gegeneinander
allein dass die neuen box vertrag haben
so das erinnert mich auch schon wieder
so ein bisschen krass analogen paul und
so
aber wir schauen uns mal weiter die
kommentare an die immer nice klick baic
mach weiter so korosec und immer schön
abgehoben bleiben mein bester ich feiere
sh hldg ag liegt es faktisch gar kein
blaues auge blickt page so klika hashtag
klick waits gut gefällt commons café de
lucia warum dieses template
normalerweise wenn ich auf videos von
anderen youtube an reagiere suche ich
mir so 10 bis 15 kommentare raus diesmal
man es deutlich unter acht oder neun
stück weil es einfach nur 160 kommentare
gibt ich weiß nicht ob da kommentare
gelöscht wurden aber 160 kommentare zu
65.000 aufrufe ist sehr sehr sehr sehr
wenig um euch seine sehr komische
relation von den aufrufen zu den
kommentaren mal zu zeigen hier dass hat
65.000 aufruf und 161 kommentare das
heißt ja mit meinen video rausgesucht
von mir was zehnmal so viele aufrufe hat
also 650.000 aufrufe da müsste man
eigentlich 1600 kommentare sein wenn man
das dann auch mal 10 rechnet bei mir
sind es allerdings 7500 kommentare also
ich glaube dass mirko da einige
kommentare weg gelöscht hat allein die
tatsache dass dort keine richtig krasser
negativer kommentar war hat mir gerade
zu denken gegeben aber gut ich würde
sagen wir gehen jetzt mal rein ins video
er sitzt in seinem zimmer ganz normale
sachen an jogging hose t-shirt das ist
der mirko immer wenn ich auf andere
youtuber reagiere sage ich dass er auch
vorher meine damen und herren ich habe
nichts gegen mirko rose persönlich habe
ich noch nie getroffen mich noch nie
persönlich mit ihm unterhalten es kann
sein dass einen echten komplett anderer
mensch ist als er sich auf youtube gibt
allerdings reagieren wäre heute auf sein
video und nicht auf ihnen als mensch
also wie gesagt kein held mirko du
kannst du korrekter typ sein aber es
geht jetzt gerade mal ums video ist
wieder back und zwar ganz kurz der beat
im hintergrund
[Musik]
hast du da die rechte daran also der
hintergrund bietet das instrumente von
monica belucci von rehn ich denke nicht
dass mich oder die rechte an hat aber
das ist eine andere sache und zwar haben
sich viele gefragt warum ich ein blaues
auge hatte in den letzten videos dazu
komme ich gleich vorher okay du hat es
in den letzten videos ein blaues auge da
schauen wir uns mal die letzten videos
an
das hier
soll es ein blaues auge sein es ist eine
wunde einfach nur hier ein blaues auge
denke ich alles drumherum blaue oder
sowie erst auf dem feld von seinem video
dargestellt als falls sie dafür noch
nicht gesehen habt freunde
das sieht nämlich so aus
jetzt schauen wir noch mal ganz kurz ins
video da sieht sein blaues auge nämlich
so aus
wenn
wir können ja auch mal so ein bisschen
durch switchen dann sehen wir hier vorne
beispielsweise immer noch hier
das ist jetzt das ist eine wunde und am
auge klar logisch ist vorhanden muss ich
zugeben sie doch schmerzhaft aus aber es
ist jetzt nicht das alles blau ist man
sieht halt sogar noch hier diesen abriss
von dem photoshop insel
was denkt man sich dann bei so was ich
verstehe allgemeine ich was bei dieser
ganzen clique miguel pablo dennis micro
sieglos ist weil mir größer nicht der
einzige der so komische sachen verkaufen
dann völlig übertrieben und kriegt mich
darstellt sondern hier
das war von miguel damals haben also hey
das ist noch schlechter als das von
mirko an der stelle natürlich klar
freunde ich selber habe auch keine
komplette weiße weste an allerdings wenn
man sich in letzter zeit meine videos
von mir ankommt auch michael prang ford
mit hans schon fragen beantworten ekels
mobile challenge meine beziehung mit dem
clever bot ich probiere eklige es
kombinationen es fast gar nichts allein
groß geschrieben und die ganzen zwei
mails ist wirklich das was passiert also
ich versuche mich dahingehend wirklich
zu bessern und nicht so krasse klickt
sachen und keine ahnung was zu nutzen
und dann sehe ich bei mir so kommentare
wie luca das ist krieg bett aus grund
und keine ahnung xy wundern sich sowas
also aber wir schauen uns mal weiter das
video an woher noch ein paar sachen weil
viele fragen sind gerade offen immer
noch zum box event box event das große
box-event hab ja gesagt ich werde mit
der kamera zu ihm gehen und gucken ob er
den box vertrag unterschreibt das ist
exakt so wie in amerika ich weiß nicht
wann er jetzt über das blaue auge redet
er spürt einfach mal bisher nicht vor
habt ihr das schon mitbekommen da poste
ich immer viel vom training schon wieder
eine minute und dem titel das will wurde
noch überhaupt nicht behandelt immer mit
der ruhe
dann ging es direkt los macht heute bei
dem kurs eimer mit sind schon welche
zehn jahre am boxen bzw a-1 machen und
er redet jetzt gerade die ganz hätte bei
seinem boxtraining buddha
das blaue auge ist beim training
passiert das macht dann wiederum sind
dann entschuldige ich mich mirco an der
stelle das ich gerade gesagt habe dass
die ersten anderthalb minuten über den
boxkampf gegen aber es kann ja wirklich
sein dass das blaue auge wirklich beim
training passiert ist dann hat dann noch
gesagt bei ihnen nicht raus gesicht hat
keinen mundschutz mit er also der mirko
war beim training für seine schöner
blick übrigens gerade der ist auf jeden
fall angekommen und dann hatten die sich
auf gewerben mit seilspringen und so
weiter und so fort und er hat dann
stimme bekommen und alles mögliche aus
sah einen mundschutz und da redet er
zweiter eben nicht aus gesicht er keinen
mundschutz mit mach dich okay wenn die
eh nicht auf meinem gesicht schlagen
dürfen der sich mehr geschlagen ich habe
sich hat es kein glück dass ich keinen
mundschutz hand und die nicht bei mir
ins gesicht schlagen sollten
ich stelle mir das einfach so gerade vor
als eher schön übrigens wieder mirko ich
stell mir das ganze vorher kommt da an
zum training und die sagen komm gegeben
den wir alles aus einem mundschutz und
sagen wie boxee mich auf's maul und er
sei ja okay dann denkt er seinen körper
die boxee box eigentlich traurig aber
die vorstellung ist kann einfach alles
doch mit ausgelöst denn da kam auch dann
direkt der sperre auge als es ist nicht
durch eine schlägerei oder sonst was ist
beim training passiert leute
solche sachen passieren manchmal
passiert manchmal dass sie dir sagen wir
haben keine mundschutz für dich für box
kommst du die komplette ladung die jungs
sind echt krass
die haben wirklich mit allem was sie
hatten draufgeschlagen gedrückt mit
allem was sie hatten
das sei damit das erste training war
richtig stabil und ich weiß zwei wochen
das erste training war richtig stabil
für sein auge er nicht und das ding ist
leute warum ich jetzt zum beispiel noch
ein trainingsvideo gemacht haben um zu
trainieren
versöhnlich ganze zeit mit der kamera
und sollen jetzt wieder das film das für
das ja aber warum willst du dann auch
film wie er den vertrag unterzeichnet
das sind auch sachen die man
normalerweise nicht film bei dem
training braucht man in polen fokus und
das war es auch eigentlich schon mit der
story zu den blauen auge also ich habe
nicht kassiert auf der straße oder
vergnügt einem anderen das wollte ich
eben nur kurz klar stellen weil das war
viel in den kommentaren habe ich ehrlich
gesagt auch erst gedacht hat sich das
thumbnail gesehen habt also no joke
dass so was kriegt man nicht vom boxen
das video ist jetzt auch vorbei wir
können wir noch ein bisschen durchs gibt
mich doppelarbeit jetzt noch dass man
irgendwie folgen soll und das ist bald
das video geben wird und das ist auch
wieder ein hammer blick also was können
jetzt abschließend sagen mir gott dieses
video hochgeladen blaues auge was
passierte mit diesem song nail finde ich
echt beschissen ich meine ja du hattest
doch eine wunde
warum stellst du dann so krass da das
macht einfach das ist einfach nur
lächerlich in england weil dieser
boxkampf zwischen karzai und wyler sehr
sehr bedacht was sie dazu raushauen die
haben natürlich auch sehr viel promo
dazu gemacht hat das ganze größer
gemacht als es ist aber zumindest nicht
mit irgendwelchen komischen aktionen wie
ja sich so total heuchlerische und
blaues auge irgendwie da rein zu
photoshop so dass man einfach nur klicks
bekommt aber an der stelle wird das
heutige wir jetzt auch beenden meine
damen und herren wenn es euch gefallen
hat meine reaktionen lassen wir das
schaffen wir 60.000 wir haben jeden fall
mega krass schreibt noch mal eure
meinung zu der ganzen sache in die
kommentare vielleicht finde nur ich das
komisch dass er sich wunden ins gesicht
photoshop zum klickst du kriegen aber
ich finde sowas muss nicht sein darf
nicht sein sollte nicht sein und so will
ich an der stelle jetzt einfach nur noch
sagen